wie lang seid Ihr hier denn schon so am
scrollen wenn ihr ein Kind in China wärt
dann könnt ihr jetzt ganz bald Schluss
sein genauer gesagt für unter
achtjährige soll es ein Limit geben von
40 Minuten Datteln pro Tag 8 bis
16-Jährige sollen eine Stunde kriegen
und 16 bis 18-Jährige zwei Stunden so
steht's zumindest in einem Entwurf der
chinesischen internetaufsicht laut
diesem Vorschlag sollen alle Smartphones
einen sogenannten jugendschutz-modus
haben das bedeutet wenn das Alter des
Kindes eingegeben wird dann gelten
automatisch für alle Apps auf diesem
Gerät diese Regeln außerdem soll es alle
30 Minuten so eine Erinnerung geben dass
jetzt mal Zeit für eine Pause ist und
von 22 Uhr abends bis 6 Uhr morgens
sollen die Geräte weitgehend gesperrt
sein ausnahmen soll es geben für
lernapps und außerdem sollen Eltern
diese Zeiten verlängern können die
Eltern sollen außerdem regelmäßig einen
Bericht kriegen der Ihnen sagt was und
wie lange ihre Kinder da so treiben